we have some top photos making news
today number three take a look at the
Islamic states newly minted money leaked
on Twitter by an anti Isis group in
Raqqa Syria the coins match the designs
the group's Treasury Department released
last year Isis says it needs its own
currency because others have been quote
imposed upon Muslims and quote and flave
and impoverished them these coins
feature a world map stalks of wheat and
the inscriptions quote the Islamic state
and a Caliphate based on the doctrine of
the prophets interesting they were we
believe they were minted in Syria that's
what we believe
yeah I mean this is I mean they think
their indication of them as an economy
historically this is how new currencies
have been developed pointage is for
paying your own soldiers and collecting
taxes Isis pays soldiers and collects
taxes that's what a currency is the
great reporting here is that they've got
a lot of oil revenues sustained their
effort okay
next one number two Ford announced it's
smart by concept the mode of flex the
bike will connect to user smart phones
or Apple watches through a special app
to provide hands-free turn-by-turn
navigation and real-time traffic and
weather information while the bike will
be able to track your heart rate it will
also feature a no sweat mode during
which its users can just enjoy the free
ride I don't know no I'm trying to
figure out why Ford is getting into
bicycles
I don't worry be happy' mode this is the
car company this is the car company this
is the Ford the car company I wish yeah
it's interesting number one in China
it's when panda cubs are born this week
you guys artificially inseminated as
part of China's effort to increase
population I mean come on Tom that is
all if you were holding this yeah no yes
maybe I don't know it depends on where
the baseball went you know depends on
whether I was able to catch it at the
high point I've heard that's what you're
supposed to do I just think Tom if there
are photos of pandas we have to run them
on surveillance that's what we do I mean
you have to do baby photos you guys
realize pandas shut down Washington DC
two summers ago
yes we're like a solid month long period
as there was a Panda cam waiting for the
birth and then post birth I'm eight
years ago as well nine years ago yeah it
can shut down entire societies and
perhaps bring political parties together
Thomas to New Hampshire photos of pandas
and charismatic megafauna theory of
politics sorry before they get cute
against me